Hey folks, welcome back to SCP Explained.
Sorry if I seem a little out of it today,
truth be told I’ve been having real trouble
sleeping lately.
Perhaps it’s because I spend so much time
poring through the files of the SCP Foundation
Archive - There’s plenty of creatures, entities,
objects, and tales that are very effective
at making you lose sleep.
But none quite as effective as SCP-966.
Grab yourself a pot of coffee and prop your
eyelids open with some matchsticks or tape,
because you need to stay alert if you want
to survive this one.
Though when you get on the wrong side of SCP-966,
I’m sorry to tell you that your chances
of survival are extremely low.
And after experiencing its primary anomalous
effects, the question of how long you’ll
even want to survive will become disturbingly
prescient.
Like many of our explorations into the living
nightmares that the SCP Foundation deals with
on a daily basis, the best way to experience
exactly what SCP-966 can do is to take a look
at a case study regarding one of its many
unfortunate victims.
In this case, that victim is a man named Terry
Halberg from New Mexico.
In another life, perhaps Terry would have
been an ideal candidate for a Junior Researcher
position at the SCP Foundation: He was a scientific-minded
truth seeker whose interests lied in the more
esoteric fields of study.
Namely, ghosts and aliens.
Proving the existence of life in the stars,
and the supernatural in general, was something
he considered to be his life’s work.
This was why he moved to New Mexico, home
of Roswell, and widely considered to be the
UFO Capital of the United States, in the first
place.
There, he’d performed experiments on a wide
range of bizarre phenomena - from exploring
haunted houses to obsessively watching the
sky for any anomalous activity.
He’d become a big wig in his niche online
paranormal investigation community, and his
posts on the somewhat infamous Parawatch forum
always garnered plenty of attention.
But Terry wanted more.
He wasn’t in it for the fame, or the money,
or the legions of insatiable paranormal investigator
groupies.
He was a true believer.
He wanted a close, first-hand experience with
the supernatural.
And that was exactly what he was about to
get, in addition to a very harsh lesson about
being careful what you wish for.
It began when he got called out to Albuquerque
for a strange case of cattle mutilation.
For those who don’t frequent the Parawatch
forums quite as often as Terry, cattle mutilation
is the most common nickname for the phenomenon
of large livestock - usually cows - being
found dead with unusual mutilation patterns
on their corpses.
While the particulars of what exactly this
means varies from believer to believer - with
theories ranging from aliens to Black Helicopters
- it is widely accepted across all branches
of paranormal enthusiasts that when cattle
are being mutilated, something very strange
is afoot.
Terry arrived at the ranch, and with the application
of a little cash to grease the appropriate
palms, he was able to conduct a recorded interview
with the rancher.
He was a weathered man in his early sixties,
with a somewhat frantic demeanor and profoundly
tired eyes.
When Terry asked him if he’d experienced
any unusual phenomena in the days leading
up to the cattle mutilation incident, he was
surprisingly forthcoming about the hellish
conditions he’d been experiencing lately.
The strange experiences had been going on
for several days now.
It all started when the rancher noticed that
a number of his cows weren’t sleeping.
This isn’t the easiest thing to spot in
a cow, because cattle engage in what is known
as polyphasic sleep, where instead of sleeping
for one prolonged period like humans typically
do, they sleep in small intervals throughout
a 24 hour period.
Cows can even sleep standing up for periods
of light rest, but during REM sleep - which
all mammals need for healthy functioning - they
lay down just like us.
The problem was, in the last several days,
many of the rancher’s cows hadn’t slept
at all.
It was after this that the rancher seemingly
began to have bizarre paranormal experiences
himself.
It began with a general sense of unease and
dread, which was soon followed by a sense
of severe insomnia that left him completely
unable to sleep for the past two days.
During this period, things had gotten worse.
He’d experienced strange noises around his
home.
Footsteps, what sounded like hushed voices,
and occasionally even what could only be identified
as a low, croaking growl.
But it wasn’t just noises, there was also
physical evidence of some kind of intrusion.
Items had been knocked over or moved.
At one point, a glass of water - which had
been centralized on a stable surface - had
somehow fallen off the edge and shattered.
The old rancher, with a trembling voice, even
stated that he’d seen things moving in the
corners of his eyes.
Figures, shapes, little green men…
And then, the cattle mutilation spree began.
It may have sounded morbid, but Terry had
to use everything in his power to stop himself
from smiling from ear to ear.
While this was a terrifying experience for
the rancher, for Terry, this was an absolutely
textbook case of paranormal experience.
And here he was, the very first person to
document it all!
It could be the next Skinwalker Ranch or Rendlesham
Forest incident, and his name would forever
be attached to it.
He asked the rancher if he could see the cow’s
body, and the rancher obliged.
Whatever had caused this - alien, ghost, or
otherwise - had really done a number on this
cow.
Good portions of its abdomen had been torn
away, with evidence of what appeared to be
biting and clawing.
This poor beast had been eaten alive.
While exploring the wounds with a magnifying
glass, a scalpel, and a large pair of tweezers,
Terry discovered something incredible.
Something frankly unprecedented, for a cattle
mutilation case: A piece of evidence left
behind directly by whatever had perpetrated
this act of gruesome violence.
A long, thin, and exceedingly sharp claw,
around twelve centimeters in length and broken
at one end.
New Mexico’s large predators include mountain
lions, black bears, bobcats, and coyotes,
and this claw was nothing like any of those.
In fact, it was nothing like Terry had ever
seen before.
Was this his big moment?
Had he discovered evidence of an entirely
new supernatural creature or a specimen of
extraterrestrial life?
He was practically vibrating with excitement
about this new discovery.
After thanking and paying the rancher again,
Terry took some photos, gathered some more
samples, and left.
He had everything he needed to conduct a groundbreaking
investigation into the supernatural.
Just wait until the folks on Parawatch heard
about this…
In all his excitement as he drove back home
from the ranch, he never once stopped to consider
what he might be bringing back with him.
But really, in the end, it didn’t even matter.
From the moment he stepped onto that ranch,
Terry Halberg was already doomed.
He just didn’t know it yet.
He arrived home and began to record all of
his information onto one master document.
He also began obsessively assembling outside
research, hoping to find similar cases that
he could add to this emerging pattern.
It was a mix of phenomena from both hauntings
and alien encounters.
Could this possibly be some form of alien
ghost - the dream find of every paranormal
investigator?
Terry had to still his racing heart as the
possibilities bombarded his mind.
He could have been working with the paranormal
find of the century here!
In fact, he was so excited by all this, he
didn’t even realize that he worked through
the entire night.
He didn’t sleep a wink.
After all, how could you, when such important
research needed to be done?
The burst of nocturnal energy felt like a
godsend.
The next night, not so much.
In the meantime, Terry had compiled his information
together enough to present it to his esteemed
paranormal colleagues on the Parawatch forums.
They were startled and amazed by what they
were seeing and hearing, especially the taped
interview with the rancher and the mysterious
claw.
One of Terry’s closest associates, who went
by the username Johnstation, pulled up a similar
bizarre case of a Los Angeles hiker who died
in the hills.
In the days before his death, his family and
friends reported him complaining about insomnia,
and experiencing an increasing state of paranoia
and distress.
He started taking long walks across remote
trails in hopes of tiring himself out enough
to finally get some sleep, but that time never
came.
When his corpse was found, it was mauled and
half-eaten.
Everyone assumed that a mountain lion had
killed him, and other scavengers had fed on
him before his body was found.
But now, Terry wasn’t so sure.
The more they looked into it, the more they
found strange and unpleasant deaths connected
to people suffering from what seemed like
severe insomnia.
Despite its debilitating effects, the only
type of insomnia that directly causes death
is the exceedingly rare genetic condition
Fatal Familial Inаsomnia, which couldn’t
account for the sheer number of deaths the
Parawatch team were finding.
In their minds, there was only one reasonable
conclusion: The deaths weren’t the result
of the insomnia itself, but whatever was causing
it.
It was only then that Terry noticed his own
inability to sleep, and his previous excitement
was gradually replaced with panic.
At first, he tried to keep it all in proportion,
knowing that it’s easy to invent things
to fear when you’re in uncharted territory.
But as the days passed and the sleep never
came, his worry became unassailable.
Terry knew that he hadn’t just discovered
a new paranormal phenomenon; he was becoming
one of its victims.
He became increasingly paranoid over the next
few days, taking constant EVP readings from
around his apartment in hopes of detecting
whatever was around him.
There were strange noises, frightening noises.
He just knew it!
But little did poor Terry know, there was
a very good reason he couldn’t detect his
tormentors.
While they had been in his apartment for days
now, he had no hope of ever seeing them - The
human eye’s spectrum of visible light is
around 380 to 750 nanometers, but the monsters
who had deprived him of his ability to sleep
existed somewhere around 900.
They were entirely undetectable to the human
eye.
And they were waiting for their latest meal.
As the insomnia grew worse, Terry received
some frightening news: That rancher who he’d
spoken to a few days before was found dead
on his property with severe injuries comparable
to that of a wild animal attack - Just like
his cattle, and just like all the other strange
cases that the Parawatch forum had found.
First the insomnia, then the frightening paranormal
experiences, and then…
Terry felt something warm and wet trickling
down the back of his neck.
He probably would have realized it was his
own blood, if a twenty-centimeter claw - just
like the one he pulled out of the dead cow
- hadn’t just pierced his brainstem.
Terry Halberg had finally gotten what he wanted:
A first-hand experience with the supernatural.
And all he had to do was die.
But in his defense, being saved from SCP-966
- A whole species of monsters known as the
Sleep Killers - is almost worse than being
killed by them.
When they release their deadly energy pulse,
their primary anomalous effect, which induces
sleeplessness on anyone or anything in their
immediate 20-meter radius, the effects are
permanent.
They essentially induce Fatal Insomnia, and
your only options are to die by their claws,
or live long enough to see your own body and
mind give out from the horrible effects of
true sleep deprivation.
They travel in pairs, and because of their
invisibility, you never know when they’re
lurking around you, waiting to rob you of
your sleep and then your life.
The Foundation currently has four specimens
in containment, but believe us, there are
a lot more out there, and they’re hungry.
Sleep tight...If you can.
Now go check out “Killer Living Graffiti
SCP-1155 - Predatory Street Art” and “Waldo
Finds You - SCP-4885 - Find Him” for more
terrifying monsters that’ll hunt you to
your last breath!